all right so after the trailer on the
Super Bowl we finally have ourselves our
home so wait wait I'm supposed out of
the song guardians nothing but good e'en
so we finally a couple of months before
the movie comes out and have a trailer
for solo a Star Wars story production
[ __ ] aside it's taken a while now
we finally have a trailer and we see
everything people thought they were
gonna see in the trip young Han Solo
Chewbacca Millennium Falcon sitting we
have a guy whose mask kind of looks like
a kylo Ren --is-- mask but it's not kylo
Ren and Alden Ehrenreich delivery has
hung so well not that I want him to feel
like a han Solo impersonation like I
remember any heroes one of the seasons
they had a flashback when Linderman and
everyone they were really young and the
dude who played young Linderman was
doing a Malcolm McDowell impersonation I
was like this just an impersonation
that's kind of awkward
since then I was like all right don't do
an impersonation just be your own person
but Han Solo is so [ __ ] ingrained in
the culture of the masses of people who
were Star Wars Pierce [ __ ] like myself
yeah you need to make it feel like Han
Solo and that paradox kind of makes me
feel like well the Han Solo movie just
shouldn't happen oh we meet han Solo
he's like I'm Han Solo captain the
Millennium Falcon this dudes like it's
alright we're fine we're fine I don't
see it is the same person really there's
the argument of like yeah but he needs
to age he'll get older he'll he'll grow
into it let's see if that internet
excuse making tolerance actually
translates to someone who gushed about
Star Wars movies for so long and it's
not going about the business one it's
character progression all that aside
Donald Glover looks good as Lando he's
one of the ones I'm looking forward to
in this movie granted Lando didn't say a
syllable in this trailer find that
interesting that he didn't talk at all
why didn't he talk I have to ask myself
that question Baca talked
why not Lando of all the characters like
I said Chewbacca feels like he did
before Chewbacca feels like Chewbacca I
know the rumor on the Internet's like
people who have seen the script like no
one's heard that no one said that [ __ ]
if they did they're supposed to say that
like anyone's like Disney the scripts
I'm gonna do that it does have that
guardians of the galaxy like I'm getting
a crew together kind of which is funny I
have seen that quite a few times in
movies before we're getting their crew
together to go on an adventure thing
only it's in space which makes people
say guardians of the galaxy which in my
Super Bowl trailer video I made
yesterday for the new Jurassic world
movie coming out I made a jab something
along the lines of Star Wars laws the
magic and people don't [ __ ] like it
when I do that [ __ ] which I don't blame
you a lot of people have come to my
channel cuz like this guy gushes about
stop
he wears a Star Wars curtain cape he is
a fanboy I'm not fanboy doubt about this
one it does not still have my thoughts
and feelings and not a [ __ ] robot as
that was a jab what I meant by that jab
is the fact that Star Wars was the tip
of the spirit it was the thing other
franchises wanted to be like now it
seems Star Wars wants to be like other
franchises which is funny interesting if
not fascinating that when guardians came
out people were like it feels like star
wars and now star wars comes out and
it's like it feels like guardians but at
least they have the iconic Star Wars
Disney tentacle monster oh the Janica
monster it's here and it's bigger blast
yet I didn't have a tentacle monster
except for the movie itself that
tentacle [ __ ] us all I don't hate the
last Jedi last Jedi was enjoyable
han Solo looks like it could be
enjoyable but indifferent enjoyable
after a Star Wars trailer that's not
something I'm really used to it's kind
of freaking me out in the end I know
people want me to say the trailer was
very cool when I first heard of a han
Solo movie I may have been excited for a
hot dogger ever since that moment though
it's been a gradual decline just after
this long wait of not having a trailer
after the production problems they
changed directors after they filmed the
movie then they reef films the movie
with Ron Howard just really had to come
out swinging and blow me away and it
just didn't just looks like a fun sci-fi
romp interchangeable with other fun
sci-fi wrong the fact is the biggest
selling point in this entire trailer is
this one part of this one shot right
there the Star Wars name
behold the reason we the people want to
like this seemingly average movie from
this very average trailer like Ray Kroc
saw those golden arches and the name
McDonald's it just sounds like America
right the soul of a Star Wars story
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more and remember always shoot first
that line is probably gonna be a new by
the way
[Music]